economía en directo América de France 24
Juan Pablo lucumí con nosotros en el
estudio Juan Pablo muy buena mañana
nuevamente de jueves ya estamos en
nuestro segundo bloque económico de
directo América volvemos a ver y nos
volvemos a ver y vamos a hablar Juan
Pablo de uno de los temas del día no la
reforma pensional de Francia que desde
que la propuso el presidente Manuel
macron no arrancó nada bien con el
rechazo de la mayoría de los sindicatos
del país Así es Raúl una reforma que
recordemos primero fue rechazada por los
franceses luego se detuvo con la
pandemia y regresó hace escasos nueve
días
Juan Pablo revisemos entonces las
características de esta reforma los
números principales de esta reforma que
ya los conocemos aquí Raúl son aumentar
de 62 a 64 años de jubilación esa mínima
se incrementará gradualmente en tres
meses cada año a partir de este año y
hasta el 2030 se propone unas categorías
específicas que permitirá que algunas
personas puedan jubilarse antes como el
caso de bomberos o policías los
franceses entonces deberán trabajar un
mínimo de 43 años para obtener una
pensión completa a partir de 2027 y
aquellos que comenzaron a trabajar antes
de los 20 años podrán obtener una
jubilación anticipada Así es Juan Pablo
Bueno macron también ha dicho que si no
se hace esta reforma el sistema de
pensiones sería insostenible porque lo
dice el presidente Raúl según el
gobierno de él de macron si no se hace
la reforma habrá un déficit de por lo
menos 13.500 millones de euros muchos
piden que no se haga cambios en la
actual edad de 62 años y otros que
incluso se reduzca hasta los años de
edad pero si nosotros miramos el
panorama Lo cierto es que Francia tiene
una de las edades mínimas de jubilación
una de las más bajas de Europa y miramos
el panorama tenemos que por ejemplo
Países Bajos tiene 66 años como mínimo y
67 a partir de 2024 Alemania en el 2031
Espera que aumentarlo hasta 67 años y
bueno en general 65 66 todos muy por
encima de los 65 años de edad y ya
veremos qué pasará con este vamos a
revisar ahora el tema del techo de la
duda de Estados Unidos porque hoy es un
día importante sobre este tema porque
hoy pues porque se proyecta que este
jueves el gobierno de Estados Unidos
supere su capacidad legal de
endeudamiento de 31,4 billones de
dólares este tope muchas veces Raúl es
algo simbólico porque en la mayoría de
ocasiones los legisladores amplían este
límite para que el gobierno siga
funcionando con normalidad pero en este
momento Pues en particular parece más
tenso por el roce entre el presidente
Joe biden y el nuevo presidente de la
cámara de el republicano Kevin mccarthy
y en la Casa Blanca hay dudas de que
pueda pasar con la votación escuchemos
hemos sido muy claros el límite de la
deuda
ha sido cedido tres veces si nos fijamos
solo en la última administración se hizo
de forma bipartidista es algo que
debería hacerse Sin condiciones No
deberíamos estar negociando en torno a
ello es el deber básico del Congreso
hacerlo el tesoro de millones de pagos
cada día su sistema está construido para
pagar las facturas de nuestro país a
tiempo Así que es esencial que el
congreso reconozca que ocuparse del
techo de la deuda es su responsabilidad
constitucional
De igual forma republicanos y demócratas
tienen varios meses para llegar a un
acuerdo ya que el departamento del
tesoro despliega lo que llaman medidas
extraordinarias para mantener el
gobierno en funcionamiento al menos
hasta junio qué ha pasado Juan Pablo
recientemente en nuestra región a nivel
económico Raúl pues tenemos varias
noticias empezamos con noticias de chile
porque el gobierno de Gabriel borich
rechazó la construcción del proyecto
minero y portuario domina el cual
buscaba la extracción de concentrado de
hierro y cobre el proyecto iba a costar
2500 millones de dólares y su rechazo
fue por compacto al medio ambiente con
el ánimo de esquivar la presión de la
inflación el ministro de economía de
Argentina dijo que el gobierno
recomprará títulos de deuda extranjera
por mil millones de dólares la
estrategia de Sergio massa pretende
mejorar el perfil de la deuda soberana
en dólares
y el gobierno de Lula da Silva pretende
recobrar de inversión pues la inversión
de Brasil de aquí a finales de 2026
pretende hacer cambios Fiscales para que
el gasto social pueda aumentar en ese
periodo
vamos ahora Juan Pablo lo conoce
indicadores económicos después de estas
breves de América Latina así es y
esperamos la apertura de Wall Street y
también veremos si Netflix finalmente
aumentará la suscripción de Pues
nosotros los los suscriptores Y también
si nos pondrá publicidad usted por
ejemplo que ve tanto Netflix Uy no pero
publicidad no vamos a ver qué es lo que
pasa en el día de hoy pero entonces
pasemos ahora a Asia porque las acciones
cotizaron mixtas el jueves cayeron las
acciones en Tokio pero subieron en seúl
y Sydney el anuncio de renuncia de la
primera ministra de Nueva Zelanda no
afectó los mercados en Asia Pacífico las
bolsas en Europa siguen operando
mayoritariamente a la Baja pues con el
anuncio de la presidenta del Banco
Central europeo diciendo que continuarán
endureciendo la política por lo menos
hasta medio año que nos trae como cifra
el día Juan Pablo
144.000 millones de euros Ese es el
déficit comercial que registró Japón con
el cierre de 2022 lo que supone un saldo
negativo 11 veces superior al que el
país asiático reportó en el año natural
de 2021 Juan Pablo como siempre Gracias
por toda la información económica mañana
con más mañana tendremos mucho más